[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like the answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and Speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact a 42 year old
South African surfer Chris burnish has
just accomplished what many thought was
impossible
Berta Sh paddled a surfboard unassisted
across the Atlantic Ocean
it took him 93 days to cover 4,600 miles
and almost 2 million paddle strokes and
all of this was done while standing up
the epic journey took him from Morocco
on the northwest coast of Africa past
the Canary Islands across the Atlantic
to English Harbor in Antigua in the
Caribbean Sea his custom-built board was
about 20 foot in length and weighed
1,350 pounds the board included a small
cabin in the front that allowed birders
to take shelter from the elements and a
number of tech amenities such as a water
maker a satellite phone a radio a
MacBook and a radar device to alert
other ships to his presence I wouldn't
want to get run over when you're riding
the surf board whether an exhaustion
worked hard against him as he paddled 12
to 15 hours every day surviving for
nearly three months on freeze-dried
meals because his board was riding low
in the water his feet and his ankles
were almost always wet waves threatened
to swamp him he also had several run-ins
with sharks who tried to bite his
surfboard to see if it was edible so why
did Berta Schinder this grueling
three-month journey across an ocean on a
surfboard well partly it was to test the
limits of paddle board possibilities but
mostly it was to raise money for his
favorite charities and six million
dollars came in through this heroic
journey you know the Bible tells us
charity
is the most noble human motive stay with
his friends were going to learn more as
amazing facts brings you this edition of
Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
that's one eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven now let's
join our host pastor Doug Batchelor
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and we do have lines open
if you want to call in with a Bible
question that's why we're here we don't
claim to know it all or have all the
answers but we will search the word
together here it is here's the phone
number of course it's a free call seems
like all the calls are about free now
eight hundred God says eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven with
your Bible questions or question about
living the Christian life and we'll
search the word together one more time
lines open you ready eight hundred four
six three seven two ninety seven and
once again my name is Doug Batchelor
pastor John Ross's he's probably
somewhere in the air crossing the
Atlantic Ocean now but not on a
paddleboard he's in a jet I'm guessing
and we're gonna start the program as we
always do with prayer father in heaven
thank you so much again for just this
wonderful privilege to be able to
proclaim the word via radio and I just
pray that you'll arrange these divine
appointments Lord and that the questions
asked and the answers given are all in
harmony with truth and we pray this in
Jesus name Amen
well you know I was really amazed when I
heard this report as many others have by
now about Chris British and his epic
adventure crossing the Atlantic you know
the little cabin that he had on the
front the nose of his surfboard just
barely big enough for him to crawl in
and he'd lock it up he rests during the
day when it was the hottest and that
he'd sometimes paddle all night long
when it was cool looking at the
bioluminescent trail crossing the
Atlantic and it pretty spooky when you
see whales surface and all you've got is
a surfboard not to mention the Sharks
that's a lot of life threatening
adventure and he endured it all
because of charity you know I like the
way the old King James uses the word
charity charity is another word for love
comes from that word you've heard before
agape and one of the greatest chapters
in the Bible is 1st Corinthians chapter
I'm gonna read verses 4 through 13
roughly charity suffers long and is kind
charity envieth not charity does not
boast itself it's not puffed up it does
not behave itself unseemly it doesn't
seek her own it's not easily provoked it
thinks no evil it rejoices not in
iniquity but it rejoices in the truth it
bears all things believes all things
hopes all things endures all things
charity never fails and now he closes
abides faith hope and charity these
three but the greatest of these is
charity now whenever I say the word
charity just insert the word love the
greatest of these is love greater than
faith and greater than hope and their
great love is the most important thing
Bible says God is love it defines him
the law of God has summed up in love and
you've heard the song Jesus loves you
that's what the Bible tells us friends
we have a free offer that I think would
just bless your heart all you've got to
do is call an escort
it's called a love that transforms maybe
you'd like to have that transformational
love in your life you will enjoy this
Bible study resource it's a beautifully
illustrated study guide it's free you
just got it if you call and you ask for
one we'll send it to you you need to
read it and it will touch your heart a
love the transforms if you want the free
resource this is a different phone
number it's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven again for the
free resources we mentioned during the
broadcast that's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven if
you're calling into the studio that's
800 God says with your Bible questions
we still got a couple of lines open one
more time 800 for six three seven 297
with your Bible questions if you want
the free offer I love the transforms
that other number eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
even look at it online at amazing facts
dot o-r-g alright we're gonna go to our
first caller who called in early and is
waiting patiently david you're on the
air with Bible answers live hello pastor
deck this is David from Sacramento hi
thank you for calling David my question
is about gog and magog I found them in
Revelation the book and I don't have a
Bible with me right now but I would like
to know who are what Gog and Magog are
good question gog and magog are the they
represent the enemies of god's people
now one of the keys to understanding
revelation is know a little bit about
the Old Testament because there are I
think about 404 verses in Revelation 278
of the 404 verses in Revelation can be
found almost word-for-word somewhere
else in the Old Testament so when you
look in Ezekiel 38 and 39 I'll read the
first verse for you David and the word
of the Lord came in to me saying son of
man set your face against GOG in the
land of Magog Gog and Magog represents
these people and you find them first in
Genesis 10 they were enemies of God's
people in Revelation 20 it talks about
Satan being bound because all the wicked
are dead there's nobody to tempt the
earth is in ruins and that at the end of
the 1,000 years it says the rest of the
Dead the wicked come back to life all
the wicked who've ever lived and it
calls them Gog and Magog the enemies of
God's people and they launched an attack
on the City of God now you not only find
that in Revelation where it says they
surround the beloved city that's
revelation 20 you find this also in
Ezekiel 38 and 39 where it talks about
Gog and may God come against God's
people who are dwelling peacefully and
both Revelation and in Ezekiel it says
they cover the earth like a cloud
another place that says like the sand of
the sea and God rains fire down from
heaven on them and devours him ezekiel
says he will rain down
fire in brimstone so this is at the end
of the 1,000 years when the wicked make
their final assault on God led by the
devil himself and Satan then is cast
into the lake of fire that is formed
from the fire evidently raining from
heaven David that's a great question and
you'll be happy to know we have a study
guide that talks about Gog and Magog and
what happens at the end of the
millennium and it's called
a thousand years of peace we'll send you
a free copy all you've got to do is call
in and that number once again for your
free lesson eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and we do appreciate your call with that
we're gonna go on and talk to let me see
Leslie is calling from Ed Moore Michigan
I know where that is I've been there
before
Leslie you're on the air with Bible
answers life hi thank you for calling
yeah and your question Leslie no that's
okay and your question Leslie no yeah
good question no you you read it says
later that Jonathan came and he met
David when he was hiding in the woods by
the cave of a deulim and that was the
last time they hugged each other and
made a covenant together and that was
the last time David saw Jonathan alive
after that Jonathan died in a battle
with the Philistines on the mountains of
Gilboa and that would be the last
chapter of First Samuel I think it's
chapter 30 maybe it's 31 1st Samuel but
Jonathan did see David one other time
thank you all right you're welcome yeah
you can look that up you'll see it for
yourself it's in now First Samuel oh it
may be 22 or 23 I'm trying to remember
but you'll see it there they
good question Leslie one of my favorite
stories is the stories about King David
did you know King David's name is
mentioned in the Bible more than Moses
more than Abraham and more than Jesus
David's name is the most frequently
mentioned name in the Bible about a
thousand times his name is mentioned all
right with that we're gonna talk to shun
tell who is calling from Salem Oregon
Chantal welcome you're on the air with
Bible answers live thank you for calling
and I want to tell you that I really
enjoyed a prophecy encounter I was
watching online oh good the program we
just did in Florida yes your question
okay
[Music]
Lord with all your heart and lean not on
your own understanding
so I'm when I'm faced with a situation
and I have to make a decision I I do
have some understanding and knowledge
about what's what's going on so how do i
how do I put that aside well how do I
not lean on with the information that I
do right yeah I understand what you're
saying it could sound like Solomon is
saying here don't use your own
understanding but of course Solomon
earlier in Proverbs has quite a bit
about with all your getting get wisdom
and obviously you get wisdom so you have
good judgment when he says don't lean it
means not as your principle prop
principally trust on the Lord not your
understanding because sometimes you'll
see things happening you say oh I don't
know what do I do and you can
rationalize things in your mind that
might go against God's Word and Solomon
saying don't go with your
rationalization above the Word of God
trust the Lord with all your heart and
don't put your primary trust in what you
can reason let me give you a prime
example just this week I was preaching
about King David and King Saul kept
trying to kill King Dave
and God kept delivering David and God
told David you're gonna be king but
David got so tired of running from Saul
healed reasoned in his mind and said you
know I may as well go to the Philistines
and live with him even though there are
enemies because Saul's gonna eventually
get me and maybe he'll stop searching
for me and David made a big mistake he
leaned on his own understanding in this
case instead of trusting what God had
said to him through Samuel the Prophet
and it caused all kinds of problems and
he nearly lost his family they were
kidnapped by an enemy and because he was
trusting his rationalization instead of
the Lord he later you know repented of
that and things worked out but we get
into trouble all the time when we try to
use our reasoning instead of what God's
Word is telling us but doesn't mean
don't use your reasoning in making
decisions God wants us to reason with
him what I do when I I try to use I use
the Bible as a guide as much as it
applies to the situation and I'm
constantly asking God for guidance right
in the middle and I just don't know
which way to go
I'm hoping I'll get an impression a some
kind of providential signal or something
yeah but the way the way you've
described it in your sermons I you know
you were impressed to go in this
direction or that or you impressed to
say something so you're wanting to know
the will of God regarding something
right well yes I never feel pulled in
one direction or another I just I feel
neutral and I'm and time goes by and I'm
thinking well I'm not getting any I'm
not I'm not feeling one thing or another
so yeah when you some of the criteria
that I give is first of all Jesus said
seek so you might be searching in God's
Word and say Lord give me some guidance
here look for providential openings get
Christian counsel what you're doing now
you know you're calling and asking
trying to get some guidance talk to
other people you know that know you and
get good Christian counsel the Bible
says in the multitude of counsel
their safety sometimes the Holy Spirit
will impress you you know don't put all
of your weight on impressions of the
mind or heart but that is a factor I
think that sometimes God's Spirit just
really impresses you and you get peace
about one direction and no peace about
the other so you know I've got a free
book that I'd be happy to offer you
Chantelle and it's called determining
the will of God it has all of these
points press about six more that you can
you can download it for free at the
amazing facts website or we'll send you
a copy just call 808 three five six
seven four seven and we'll send you a
copy of determining the will of God or
anybody out there if you're struggling
with some of those decisions thank you
for your call Chantelle and though we're
gonna try and get a couple more callers
we do have some lines open now and if
you want to call with your Bible
question now is a good time 800 with
your Bible question 800 for six 372 97
that's 800 God says because we're using
the Bible talking next with oh let's see
Greg Collin on line six hello Greg I bet
you didn't know you were on line six
calling from Orange New York how are you
doing good good
good evening and your question tonight
yeah there was one of the statements in
Revelation chapter 4 it has to do with
John taken up to heaven sees the emerald
rainbow around the throne room of God
you I have some insight on it I think
but what do you think of that yeah the
it says there's a rainbow round about
the throne sight unto like an emerald
and that's I think the way of chapter 4
the rainbow colors obviously are not the
same as our colors and of course is not
an
rainbow that's celebrating st. pat's a
day it's just a beautiful color of life
and you know in the world so often you
know green vivid green is so much more
the vert
emanates from him so you know I've done
a study before where numbers have
meanings in Bible in the Bible and I've
done a very vague study it's I'm not an
expert on it but I've seen some
interesting studies where people go
through the colors in the Bible and and
the meetings and the meanings of those
colors yes the the economy of each
question was the Emerald rainbow emerald
green and the rainbows multicolored well
the really doesn't mean rainbow it when
he says rainbow there he's really
talking about a bow of light you've
probably seen the moon shining through
the clouds and you see a bow around yeah
I I work off the Aramaic from the Syriac
and it says a rainbow an emerald rainbow
write the word rainbow though is talking
about just light being diffused in a bow
shape it doesn't mean that it's got the
seven colors that we see in the typical
yes rainbow I have a little yeah I have
a little understanding on that and then
the light is in seven colors what did
you thought eyes are you natural rain
bow and that reflects the seven spirits
of God revelation three four and five
so the emerald rainbow I have a little
insight on that there is from the
creation of the earth light has always
been coming on the earth from the east
with no beginning point continually
rising from the east and yet like as
like rises continually to today and dawn
breaks you have the red green blue
indigo violet violet indigo blue no
green orange orange yellow red no it's
on right let me give you something to
think about he falls away to the west
light then starts falling away into
darkness which has continually done red
orange yellow green blue indigo violet
in the Millennial Kingdom his throne
rooms gonna be on the earth and the
green is midway between the sunrise and
the sunset all right well let me give
you something to think about that you
may find
related to what you're saying is on the
breastplate of the high priests there
were twelve stones and those stones when
you do a little research there are very
similar to the colours of a rainbow
those are the same stones that are in
the foundation of the New Jerusalem so
while you're doing your study on the bow
around the throne in Chapter four you
may want to look also in chapter 21 and
22 where it talks about the foundation
stones and the New Jerusalem I think
you'll find that interesting
after you looked it up you may have
already done it I'd love to hear what
you think about that thank you for your
question Greg and we do need to keep
going here and we're gonna talk next to
Christie who's calling from Albuquerque
New Mexico Christie you're on the air
with Bible answers live evening thank
you for calling all right well first of
all you won't find the word Trinity in
the Bible there's a lot of words that we
use to describe things in the Bible you
don't find the word millennium but the
teaching of the millennium better known
as the thousand years is there in
Revelation 20 you'll find a lot of
things that we use terms for the Bible
talks about the Godhead but it's talking
about you know who are the person so
let's first establish there is more than
one now in the Bible when it says hear o
Israel Deuteronomy chapter 6 here o
Israel the Lord our God is one when it
says that it's talking about one as in
United because jesus said a man will
leave his father and mother cleave to
his wife and they become one well
there's two of them Jesus said regarding
the apostles father John 17 Father I
pray they may be one well there is 12 of
them but it says one so for the Jewish
mind one meant unity because many of the
pagan gods they had different gods with
their different territories and they
fought with each other like the Greek
gods and that God are the bushes and the
trees and the birds and the bugs and uh
and God said no our God is a one God but
in Genesis God says let us make man in
our image
so you've got some plurality there right
at the beginning at the baptism of Jesus
you've got God the Father who says this
is Matthew chapter 3 God the Father says
this is my beloved son Jesus is in the
water then God the Spirit comes down in
the form of a dove there you get the
three jesus said go Matthew 28 go
baptize in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit and so through
eternity
God the Father Son and spirit are
eternal because God has always been
loved and you cannot have love with one
person love is always made real in
giving to others or expression to others
and so the God always manifests himself
in these three persons that are unique
individuals of God the Father and their
functions seem different God the Son and
God the spirit and I just was reading
let me look here just yesterday I was
reading the first chapter of first Peter
I'll look there real quick Peters is an
apostle chapter 1 verse 1 of 1st Peter
Peter an apostle Jesus Christ to the
strangers scattered throughout Pontus
Galatia Cappadocia Asia and Bithynia
elect according to the foreknowledge of
God the Father through sanctification of
the Spirit obedience and sprinkling the
blood of Jesus Christ the right there in
the introduction he says the father the
son the spirit you see that I'll being
mentioned I've got a free book I'll send
you Cristian the Trinity would you like
a copy of that it all you've got to do
is call amazing facts and call this
number 880 five six seven four seven say
I'm listening to amazing facts I'd like
that free book on the Trinity I'll send
it to you just please read it you'll see
a lot more scripture than I have time to
share in our short broadcast but we do
have another line or two open and I'm
gonna take another call before our
midway break talking next to dawn who's
calling from Sacramento Don you're on
the air with Bible answers live hello
good evening evening I'm calling about a
scripture I
member that goes something like this I
don't have it right in front of me but
it goes something like oh that men would
praise the Lord for his mercy and
goodness to the children of men yeah
and my question and what would you say
are some of the best ways that a man can
praise the Lord for the Lord's mercy and
goodness um what is the best way or just
some some of the ways or some of the
better ways or what maybe is the best
way you know when we I think the best
way for us to praise God is when we live
consistent Christian lives we praise God
when we tell others what he has done for
us that's what it means to praise Him
there are some Christian programs where
they say let's all praise the Lord and
they sort of wave their arms in the air
and they repeat over and over praise the
Lord praise the Lord well that's not
praising God that says making noise
really the way you praise the Lord is by
extolling his virtues in his character
so when we say God is good or when we
tell people God has been so good to me
or God has provided and God has blessed
we are praising God we're giving him
credit or we're attributing to him his
you know beautiful qualities that's
really how you praise God and then
living out his teachings in your life is
you know exhibit a of praising God it
means I believe in him and I'm gonna
live my life to glorify Him and it's in
Psalms the verse where you say that we
might praise God for his wonderful works
to the children of men so yeah I see
yeah they're saying okay that's the
great answer thank you alrighty thank
you very much Don appreciate your
question and with that you know how much
time we got left oh we got one minute
tell you what friends we're just gonna
have a break in a moment it's not fair
to start a question and just cut you off
don't go away matter of fact we've we're
gonna get all your I think everyone yeah
we should be able to get everybody lined
up and we have a line or two open here's
the phone number if you want to call in
with your Bible question it's 800 God
says 8 hunt
four six three seven two nine seven I
see one operate in there looking bored
and so why don't you give them a call
and ask a Bible question and they'll
pass it on here to us in the studio want
to remind you that amazing facts is
really available all week long if you
have any other Bible questions or
interests or studies just go to amazing
facts dot o-r-g amazing facts has just
gobs and scads and a blizzard a
kaleidoscope a plethora of resources and
amazing facts dot o-r-g there's videos
you can watch they've got amazing facts
of faith like we have here on the radio
program a lot of resources you can
download for free amazing facts dough
are g gonna take a brief break for a
station ID and coming back with your
Bible questions in just a moment
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
amazing facts has impacted manage space
guy for amazing facts amazing facts
actually did have an impact his thought
process getting to Maryam today I began
reading the Bible I got baptized into
his death I realized that there had to
be more of the light is really doing
that is the life that he's given this
message was so powerful I swear he knows
amazing facts more than 45 years of
proclaiming God's message around the
world and in the logo pops across
amazing facts presents I've listened to
a lot of different ministers but he was
this was the first time that he's
actually saying something where I had to
grab my Bible actually pick it up and
I've never heard this before let me let
me look through and find this that I
just couldn't get enough and so I
started doing Bible studies every single
one of these guys started being changed
including myself my question was why did
that happen to me God the Lord was able
to reach out and I actually saw him as a
father I lost everything and that was
when I realized that it was God missing
in my life I went to a prophecy seminar
which knocked me out this message was so
powerful and so irrefutable
I just went this is real this is this is
amazing
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 phone call
we'll do our best to search the word
together and my name is Doug Batchelor
pastor Ross is on his way back from a
weekend of evangelism in South Africa we
let him go to his hometown for a little
while and he'll be back with us again
next week and we're gonna go back to the
phones let's see I think Patti has been
waiting patiently Patti you're on the
air with Bible answers live hi hi thank
you for your patience
oh no problem and what's your question
lately I have a question if we are saved
by faith so that no man can boast then
what does it mean when we go for the
judgement if our sins are put as far as
from the east to the west and what is
the judgment well when that's a good
question
when we're when we come to Jesus and
were saved we are saved by faith and
when we accept Christ by faith then we
begin to live anew
and the Bible says old things are passed
away all things are made new were born
again were new creatures and there's a
difference in the life when we love the
Lord he says if you love me keep my
Commandments meaning that if we do love
him the result of that is we're gonna
want to obey Him and in the judgement it
will determine we're saved by faith but
if we are saved
jesus said you'll know them by their
fruits and so there will be a difference
in the works so the works we're not
saved by works but the works are
evidence that we've been saved does that
make sense
so if a person is saved there will be a
difference in their works even Paul says
when he says in Ephesians there you know
we're saved by grace through faith he
says we are saved for good works and
then we're saved by our works of Meno
then we're judged by our works and we're
saved again accordingly or well no we're
saved entirely by faith but when we are
saved by faith there's gonna be a
difference in the life and you know
Jesus said there'll be many that will
come in the last days and they'll say
Lord Lord you know we cast out devils
and we did many wonderful works so say I
don't know you they're trusting in their
works but then he says depart from me
you who work iniquity he said he said
you love me you said you serve me but
your works aren't showing that let me
give you one more example okay patty you
with me yeah I'm like yeah Matthew
chapter 25 verse 31 Jesus tells a
parable of the great Judgment Day where
he separates the sheep from the goats
right right right and then that parable
what he says to the Sheep he says well
done good and faithful servants enter
into the joy of the Lord you're saved
for when I was hungry you fed me when I
was thirsty you gave me drink when I was
naked you clothed me when I was sick or
in prison you came to me so what is he
judging them by it works
they sure they're you you love your
gentrified where exactly there he's God
saying did you love your neighbor when
you're saved by faith is it a faith it's
just verbal it's like James says if you
show me your faith without your works I
will show you my faith by my works so
Christ says then he says to the Lost I
was hungry you didn't feed me I was
naked and you know you can't feed and
clothe everybody in the world but God
gives us opportunities as believers to
do good to all people and you know if we
really say we love God then he says
prove it and show love to one another
and so that's what I just it just seemed
seems like a conflict sometimes huh yeah
going your you think okay you've been
forgiven your sins are you worried that
your works aren't good enough and that's
why you're asking this probably young
well let me get send you a free study I
think will encourage you and it's about
the subject of grace and law and the
book is called does God's grace blot out
the law and it's a beautiful book that
explains how we're saved by faith and
what role does works or law have and I
think you'll find it says we're saved
entirely by faith but then it helps
people understand well what is the
function then of obedience or works or
the law because you know it's all
interchangeable really I understand
we're supposed to be obedient yeah look
can I say that a free copy of that
that'd be great thank you
yeah it's called those God's grace blot
out the law asks for the book on Grayson
law when you call 808 three five six
seven four seven and I think that you'll
be blessed by that that does free up a
line if someone wants to call with a
question again eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven thank you
very much patty I'm gonna talk now to
Susan who's calling from Cabazon
California I've been to Cabazon hello
Susan hello you're on the air
yes my question is is that if we get
married in front of God just the two of
us are we married in God's eyes when you
mean just two people no witnesses yeah I
mean like if two people go to the Lord
and they do their valves and it's just
and the Lord are they married in the
Lord's eyes you know I used to think
that when I was young I used to think
well marriage is really between God and
and the only one present when Adam and
Eve got married was God and they were
certainly married and so why do I need
to have a service and a minister and all
the government of aldeman and license
and blood tests and and you know the
more I studied it as I got older I
realized marriage was marriage is a
covenant and covenants usually have
witnesses and then I started asking the
question why wouldn't you want to be
married where you have it public that's
really an important question and if if
marriage is something let me let me just
have you think about something if two
people walk out of closet and they just
you know people start wondering are you
guys married what's what's going on well
you tell him yes or no and well when did
you get married well we got married when
we were you know in that room why didn't
you invite anybody well we didn't want
anyone to know or we didn't want have to
pay them for a marriage license it just
you know the Bible says let all things
be done decently and in order
why wouldn't you want to do it according
to the law I guess just because it's so
expensive and a lot of people don't well
you can have an expensive wedding and be
legal you can get married by Elvis
pretty cheap in Las Vegas I'm not
recommending that but they have some
pretty cheap weddings so it you don't
have to you know spend thousands of
dollars you can go to a justice of the
peace and it's then becomes you have two
witnesses you you know everyone's got a
couple friends but you you hate to say
when you love someone you've made it
the supposed to last for life and you
say well we you know we just kind of did
it ourselves it starts sounding a little
bit it's like a secondhand wedding and
there are some states that recognize
common-law wedding then by the way what
I'm talking to you about this I'm
talking to myself cuz I used to believe
that it doesn't matter and and you know
just you can have a hippie wedding and
call it marriage but I've come to
believe that I think the Bible says obey
the laws of the land and things should
be done decently and if you're Christian
you know you do it in the presence of
God and others and one of the first
miracles of Jesus was at a wedding and
there were plenty of witnesses from what
you read so yeah I hope that helps a
little bit but it's a good question I
know others are asking it because I did
and thank you very much Susan I I do
have a book I can send you a study guide
I'll send you a free copy on keys for a
happy marriage and I think you'll get a
blessing out of that keys for happy
marriage anyone out there that wants to
know what are the Bible keys for a happy
marriage we'll send it to you to you
notice all through this broadcast we
offer most of our resources for free and
if you'd like a copy that it's 800 call
this number this is a different from the
studio Christian number it's eight
hundred eight thirty five six seven four
seven we've got a bank of gifted young
people that are Manning the phones for
us and they will pray with you and
they'll take your requests and get your
address and mail you the study guides
that's how we do it
I appreciate your call Susan we're gonna
talk next to Stanley calling from
Philadelphia Pennsylvania Stanley you're
on the air with Bible answers live hey
Doug I hope you're adjusting to the post
Chuck Berry era better than I am I'm
depressed over that but that was some
good things hey you know I'm a huge fan
of your show I catch you a couple times
a month and have for several years now
but I never listen when you're throwing
when you slap on a tape I turn off the
radio because call-in radio that is not
live should be dead don't you agree
oh well I sometimes I can't
be omnipresent so we want to have the
program every week you know the reality
is Stanley that for every person that
calls in there's about 2,000 listening
that don't call and so he could cancel
the program if I'm traveling radio but I
think that is wrong I listen for the
caller's every bit as much for the hosts
as I do for the hosts in fact many shows
I really prefer the caller's to those I
know so there's an issue that has been
coming up repeatedly over the decades
for me and and it's been I'm the
president in my mind to steal a word
from you it's been omnipresent in my
mind of late because it's something I've
been watching on well it's a cable show
but I catch it on YouTube and the
question is and you if you get some
biblical citations here that are
applicable feel free to toss them in but
the general question is what sort of
sort of commonality sort of interplay
sort of intersection should the non
believing and believing communities have
and and the regional I've been thinking
about this a lot lately is it because
I've been watching something called the
atheistic experience out of Austin and
they always encourage and and
successfully encourage Christians to
call and the debates are fascinating to
listen to and and learn a lot and I've
had my mind changed here and there by
both callers and those and how do you
stand on this question Doug all right
well on the question of interacting I do
think it's important if people are
honestly open and they want a dialogue
and debate you know is there a god we're
living in a society where I've seen a
few studies i sat down at a dinner
earlier this year and started talking to
the person next to me and lo and behold
it was George Barna who's the one of
course started the Barna survey research
group and there's some studies out that
show that gradually the United States is
becoming less and less of a
Christian country than it used to be and
so I think we need to know how to engage
atheists and in a loving way of course
you always cringe when you hear some you
know a Christian that wants to be
combative debating or talking with an
atheist and they're not giving logical
reasons they're just saying well the
Bible says and Chrissy atheists is
thinking well so I think when you're
talking to atheists you can't use the
Bible as your source book you need to be
able to give them logical reasons why
the Bible is dependable and why you
believe what you believe I used to be an
atheist and so when someone said well
but the Bible says I thought well so
what you believe a book why do you
believe that book and you have to get
past that and and understand that the
Bible is a dependable document and so
having those kind of interactions I
think are very are very helpful and hey
I appreciate all your kind words Stanley
and we're gonna take a couple more
callers here thank you very much for
your question talking next to Leigh
who's calling from is it can uh Virginia
Lee you're on the air with Bible answers
live thank you very much taking like oh
yes and how can we help you tonight well
the question I have I was actually
listening to an earlier radio program
and I will say I myself you know I've
answered the call to ministry and you
know avid avid Bible reader I try to
study learn as much as I can and the
question I had I heard a very
experienced minister make the comment
earlier that salvation through grace was
not sufficient that water baptism was a
requirement of true salvation and I had
never believed that you know I believe
that the grace of Jesus Christ is
sufficient enough I preached on that
that has been my message through at all
and I wonder what your thoughts are on
that about the necessity or lack thereof
of water baptism
well there's a lot of things that God
calls us to do when we accept him but we
are not saved by doing those things God
calls us to support his work with tithes
and offerings but if for some reason a
person doesn't or can't they're not
saved because they did or didn't do that
among the things God calls us to do when
he loves us when we love him and were
surrendering to him you know Jesus said
go therefore teach all nations baptizing
them but the thief who died on the cross
next to Jesus and Christ promised he
would be in paradise he didn't get
baptized and so obviously baptism you
know Christ gave him grace probably gave
him credit for his own baptism because
Jesus was baptized not for his sin so I
suppose that you know some of us just
like Jesus did not die for his death we
get credit for his death I would think
that those who can't be baptized they
get credit for his baptism by His grace
I've been in the hospital or been in a
prison where a person is on death row or
they're dying hooked up to machines and
they can't get baptized but they accept
Christ I expect to see them in the
kingdom based on the grace of God so is
baptism important very important you
know Jesus said unless you're born of
the water in the spirit you cannot enter
the kingdom of heaven but it's not we're
not saved by it if a person can't be
there'll be people in heaven that did
not know you should only have one wife
like King David and and Solomon and what
many others I could name you know Jacob
man Abraham well it's a sin I think for
a man to have more than one wife at a
time or woman to have more than one
husband there'll be people in in heaven
that you know had all kinds of problems
I think there's gonna be people that
weren't baptized biblically or they
weren't baptized at all but they just
didn't know and if you read in Acts
chapter 17 I think it's verse 30 it says
at the times of this ignorance God
winked at by the grace of God sometimes
they just don't know they're living up
to the light they have and he
that they're ignorant so we're all saved
by grace and I'm sure when I get to
heaven I'm gonna find out some things
that I got wrong oh I know there's a lot
of things that get wrong I know about
but there's probably some I don't know
about and I'm not trusting in my knowing
and everything and doing everything
right I'm trusting in His grace
so baptism is important I don't want to
understate that but we're not saved by
baptism we're saved by a faith love
grace hey I've got a book I can send you
if you're likely it's a I'll send your
free copy and it's just called baptism
is it necessary and I think it has a
really good balanced approach would you
like that yeah just don't be afraid to
call one more number just so they can
know where to send it
if you call 808 three five six seven
four seven anyone that wants to
understand this subject 808 three five
six seven four seven it's a great study
and we'll send you a free copy thank you
for your good call appreciate that Lee
and next we're gonna be talking to
Philip with Bible name Philip calling
from Texas listening on satellite radio
welcome Philip you're on the air
thank you I had a question but the lady
that brought up the question about works
judgment you know the the believer saved
will be judged with their works to see
if they receive rewards you know and
Jesus said a man who gives a child a cup
of cold water in his faith will not lose
the reward and yeah I had my brother
tell me well why do you want rewards so
so you could have a beautiful crown yeah
there are varying degrees of reward in
the kingdom and even Jesus told the
Apostles that and some of that judgment
is going to determine the extent of
reward and you know I don't know if some
are gonna have heavier crowns and others
or if it's going to be just closer to
the Lord or
or like the Monopoly board you'll have
you'll have a mansion Jesus has been
prepared that's going to be more Park
Place and boardwalk than but you know
does that matter I just want to be there
I mean I just say Lord I just want to be
there you know no one wants to be saved
by the skin of their teeth but boy I'll
be happy to be there
now was that your question or did you
have another one I think that'll do it I
just wanted to say that that it is real
important your works will be judged not
to not for your salvation but for your
reward you know a position of doing
something with the Lord you might have a
job to do we cannot yeah it's gonna be
wonderful but not only that you know
part of what it says about the judgment
and the works it's not just the saved it
says even the wicked are judged
according to their works
and the lost the books are opened and
they're cast into the lake of fire and
evidently there's not only a varying
degree of reward for the saved the
Bible's very clear there's a varying
degree of reward for the loss and Jesus
said he who did many things wrong is
beaten with many stripes and that's you
know figurative but there's varying
degrees of reward appreciate your call
and your question Philip and I'm gonna
be let me see here I think Christina is
next Christina calling from Arkansas
you're on the air with Bible answers
live hi Christina sometimes the phone is
muted are you there stepped away from
the phone calling a year on the air with
Bible answers live you have a question
oh I'm not Christina oh well you know we
may have the wrong name type yeah what
is your name I'm Bob Bob let's take your
call Christina's probably saying Here I
am Hagar Christina I see you now I punch
the wrong button your your question Bob
at chapter 23 verse 3 it's talking about
tootie's there as to her unleavened
bread first fruits etc yeah and but
first it talks about
[Music]
to speak to the children of Israel that
these are the feasts of the Lord you
shall proclaim to be my holy be holy
convocations these are my feats but then
it seems like that it switches gears and
and talks about the Sabbath and then
verse 4 these are the feasts of the Lord
so I mean this was wandering was the
Sabbath in the same categories the other
feasts is verse 3 he's supposed to be a
feast of authority just somehow just
detouring and saying the Sabbath you
need to keep anything well I think the
Lord deliberately says I want to talk to
you now about the feasts they are annual
convocations is what he's talking about
and then as a parenthetical statement he
says now six days you work and the
seventh is the Sabbath he's basically
saying this is not a feast this is a
holy weekly convocation and then he says
now these are the feasts and so he
actually I think God is deliberately
through Moses setting the Sabbath in a
different category it's one of the Ten
Commandments and so he's saying as I'm
talking about the feasts keep in mind
these are annual feasts they come once a
year the weekly Sabbath is different
from the annual Sabbath's and he's
actually drawing that out before he gets
into the various feasts and we often do
that when we're coming him yeah but this
100 person was trying to tell me that
since it's in in in the thing there in
verses 1 through 4 etc it's supposed to
be a tstanners but it doesn't sound like
that to me though no I think Moses is
he's going he's going out of the way to
completely separate he says look I'm
gonna talk to you now about the feasts
and all of them that he mentions the
seven annual feasts are annual and then
he stops before he gets into it and he
says now six days your work is done the
seventh day says this is weekly it's not
annual is the Sabbath this has gone back
to Adam and Eve as a part of the Ten
Commandments don't do any work in it
it's a holy convocation then he says
these are the feasts you even holy
convocations proclaim them in their
seasons different from the weekly cycle
and so he pulls it out as something
separate I've got a free book I can send
you it's called feast days and Sabbath's
if you like a copy Robert okay tell you
what let's do that
call the resource line eight three five
its course 808 three five six seven four
seven ask for a free book on feast days
and Sabbath's and I made such a big deal
out of trying to get a hold of Christina
I need to take her call Christina and
now you really are on the air hi thank
you sorry I was calling you before and
I'd press the wrong button well when I
heard a man's voice I thought well maybe
her Huff's the husband came to the phone
but I passed the Rosses in here and he
usually does the phone so I got mixed up
and your question tonight my question
has to do with directly from God are the
other laws also directly from God or
were they all of them were the Word of
God is all the law all the Bible is all
considered the Word of God there were
laws that were in a different category
that were called ordinances and if you
look in Deuteronomy chapter 4 it makes a
distinction there when it talks about
them and let me see if I can find that
for you real quick
deuteron chapter 4 if I go to oh let me
see where is it verse 29 he says that
you know you've got he declared unto you
his law even ten commandments which he
commanded you to perform and the Lord
gave me at that time these statutes and
these ordinances so you've got the law
and then you've got the let me see here
huger yeah I can't find it
yeah it's in Deuteronomy chapter 4 he
talks about the the yeah he says that
you got the Ten Commandments and the
statutes and ordinances Ten Commandments
are of an eternal nature it's always
wrong to lie
steal kill so forth then you've got law
that was health laws which is just good
practical information for sanitation and
health and long living then there were
ceremonial laws that were to be
connected with the sanctuary and the
sacrifices to help them recognize Jesus
when he came and so I'll be happy to
send you a free book that talks about
written in stone and it will help you
understand the the relationship of long
grace call 883 five six seven four seven
ask for written in stone we'll send you
a free copy Kristina and anyone who asks
Thank You friends for listening to Bible
answer is live tonight it's been a
pleasure it always seems like it goes so
fast and if you want to keep studying
with us we're here every week you could
also go to us every hour of the day and
amazing facts not Largey god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G are you wondering what
lies ahead in human history or what the
recent world events are harbingers of
the end are you ready for the coming
crisis landmarks of prophecy offers
clear answers to your most pressing
questions presented by Pastor Doug
Batchelor landmarks of prophecy is a
contemporary video Bible study adventure
designed for today's audiences
presenting the landmark themes of the
Bible and a bright and compelling way
helping you understand the Bible better
and giving you knowledge to face the
future with confidence landmarks of
prophecy contains over 30 hours of
exciting video presentations on six DVDs
plus bonus question and answer sessions
giving you keen insight into what lies
next in human history if you'd like
practical tools to help you thrive and
survive in the here and now get
landmarks of prophecy start your epic
Bible study adventure with landmarks of
prophecy today by calling
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF Axio RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore comm which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]